the struggling US newspaper industry is
caught up in a costly trade dispute that
is pushing up its production costs
ground wood paper is used in newsprint
production and most of it comes from
Canada the Trump administration put a
tariff on those imports because of
concerns the paper was subsidized by the
Canadian government and sold at below
market prices
tomorrow the Commerce Department will
announce whether it will end that tariff
we visited the New York Times printing
plant in New York City this is the stuff
that is in the crosshairs of this debate
on tariffs this would Paul goes and it
comes from Canada all of on this print
custom panel nearly 70% of newspapers in
the US rely on this ground wood paper
Nick D'Andrea the vice president of
production at the New York Times says
the tariff has made printing on paper
that much harder newspapers have their
own challenges already our job is to try
to protect the revenue of the printed
newspaper ken dr. a news industry
analyst says the tariff is a blow to a
print industry already in decline this
is the kind of unexpected event that
happens and it takes an industry that
may be hurting a little and makes it far
worse as a result small newsrooms have
had to make tough choices from laying
off staff to cutting the number of pages
they print those tariffs have caused a
increase in newsprint pricing of about
30 to 35 percent beyond the tariffs
declining print readership overall has
caused printing plants to make
adjustments at the new york times
printing plant in queens over 600,000
newspapers are rolled out every night
but not all copies are of the New York
Times past any one of the things that
we've done over the
couple years as we try to bring more
business in so we've slaughtered
printing USA today here just recently we
started printing Long Island Newsday
here and that's happening nationally the
consolidation so in response to
declining print circulation plants like
yours are now printing for other
newspapers not just the times in the
last decade weekday print newspaper
circulation has dropped by over thirty
million nationally the market for news
and how people consume it has changed
dramatically particularly in the last
five or six years in just five years as
chief operating officer at the New York
Times meredith cope at Le'Veon has
witnessed a 40% drop in subscribers to
the times daily print papers it's called
a newspaper yeah but are we even gonna
have the paper part in ten years the
question is will we have quality
original independent journalism
available to the masses in ten years and
I think the answer is yes but it
requires that news organizations make
digital experiences that are as
addictive and unrivaled as the
journalism itself
The Times readership is increasingly
going digital in just the last year
they've seen an increase of close to 1
million online subscribers but not all
papers have been able to pivot so
successfully last week The Daily News
laid off half its staff and in March the
Denver Post cut its newsroom by a third
we are in a scary time for local
journalism and I think quality original
independent journalism at the local
level is like foundational to community
to society and ultimately to democracy
it's a very tough story for local papers
right now right there there's the
existential threat here in terms of
digital but there's also tariffs that
are we're going to be debating I think
roundly in the next couple days they
those have made an already difficult
industry that much harder all right